Philanthropic investor and I invest
primarily in
early childhood education and services.
I've
spent quite a bit of time and money on
the subject of early literacy.
Uh,
what I did in my business career,
I would describe as I applied systems
solutions to large business problems.
I was in the early days of Federal
Express building.
I was the chief information officer back
then after I had left IBM and other
private businesses and I was,
did that for a while,
building the worldwide trade shipping
tracking system.
And then I was chief operating officer
of Federal Express for about 10 years,
uh,
implementing lots of systems,
aviation systems,
computer systems.
So I learned a great deal
from that experience.
Then I went and ran a largest,
then the largest solar company in the
world,
and mccaw cellular out of Seattle.
Uh,
we sold that to a t and t and became
chief executive officer of at and t
wireless back in the early nineties.
Uh,
and then I left that at the behest of
some people who are now great friends of
mine to go with a little startup.
I figured one more bite at the apple,
so I went down to Palo Alto and mountain
view California and became the chief
executive officer of a little startup
called netscape communications,
and we taught the world how to use the
Internet with the browser.
And then we sold that to aol in
[inaudible] 99.
And,
uh,
that's when I basically retired from
active business.
Went on the Time Warner Board.
Uh,
I'm on several boards,
both public and private.
I'm chairman of the board of the Mayo
Clinic,
Rochester,
Minnesota,
and on other private boards interested
in healthcare and human service.